Have you ever been walking on the beach and
happened upon a tidepool?
Suddenly, you find an entire world contained
in that pool of water; little creatures swimming
around and going about their lives, completely
oblivious to the giant watching them from
above.
There’s something incredible about that,
the way whole worlds can exist inside something
so small.
In the Central Sahara Desert, the SCP Foundation
discovered a tiny world of their own like
nothing anyone has ever seen before: SCP-6011,
also known as The Flat Earth.
Not to be confused with the Flat Earth your
least favorite aunt keeps posting about over
on Facebook.
SCP-6011 is a circular area hanging about
5 centimeters in the air.
The radius of the area spans roughly 500 meters
and is buried 156 meters below the ground
within a deposit of limestone.
The SCP exists as a two-dimensional plane,
three-dimensional objects passing through
as if they were not there at all.
All of the materials found within SCP-6011,
both organic and inorganic, resemble their
three-dimensional counterparts.
There are a wide variety of living organisms
within SCP-6011, designated SCP-6011-1.
The smallest instance of SCP-6011-1 resembles
ordinary earth-based single-celled organisms.
The most notable species of SCP-6011-1 is
referred to as Plana hominem, the closest
thing SCP-6011 has to human beings.
Members of Plana hominem resemble the side
profile of a human, with a visible head that
includes a brain, a nose, and an eye.
They also have distinct muscular, lymphatic,
respiratory, digestive, nervous, endocrine,
cardiovascular, urinary, and reproductive
systems.
The only way for Plana hominem to move is
via several cilia-like structures that they
can also use to pick up objects.
Dr. Michalis was assigned to head the research
into SCP-6011 and its various residents.
In pursuit of further knowledge of Plana hominem,
Dr. Michalis decided to select a subject to
interview about the nature of SCP-6011.
He settled on an educated individual named
Iotis, and decided to initiate contact.
Iotis was playing a game alone in his office
when Dr. Michalis played a short, high-pitched
noise on a speaker suspended 5 centimeters
above them.
Startled by the sound, Iotis reacted, calling
out “Pardon?”
When Dr. Michalis spoke, Iotis was immediately
perplexed and frightened, unable to see where
his voice was coming from.
He moved around the room, feeling the walls,
searching for the source of the mysterious
voice as Dr. Michalis insisted that they move
to the North and stop looking.
Iotis threatened to call the police, accusing
Dr. Michalis of being a thief who had invaded
his home.
Dr. Michalis attempted to calm Iotis down,
reminding him that his yelling would disturb
his son and daughter.
This only upset the subject further, and he
accused Michalis of being a stalker in addition
to a thief.
Finally, Dr. Michalis was able to subdue the
Subject by insisting that he was not a thief
or a stalker, but a messenger.
He promised no harm would come to Iotis or
his family if they would just listen to what
he had to say.
Michalis identified himself as a doctor, bonding
with Iotis over their shared education.
Iotis requested that Michalis show himself,
and, since he was unable to do so, he briefly
lowered a mechanical piston into the surface
of SCP-6011.
Though Michalis was unable to cross into SCP-6011,
this allowed him to introduce a physical presence
into the area.
After their conversation, Iotis agreed to
participate in another interview.
This particular conversation was cut short
when two police officers approached the house
after noise complaints from the neighbors.
Iotis called out to Michalis as he left, referring
to him as “Angel.”
Following this initial contact and the interview
that ensued, Dr. Michalis and his team performed
several other interviews with Iotis.
As more information was collected via observation
and conversation, Michalis decided to put
together a seminar and Q&A with Junior Researchers
at the Foundation regarding the details of
SCP-6011.
During the seminar, Dr. Michalis explained
the nature of SCP-6011 and its discovery.
It was first happened upon by Italian colonial
forces in 1912.
At the time, they thought it was an extended
form of the cave system, but the Foundation
knew better.
After introducing the Junior Researchers to
SCP-6011, Michalis provided more information
on Iotis himself.
He made it clear that Iotis is not to be mocked
for assuming Michalis to be an angel, explaining
it this way: “Imagine someone suddenly appearing
within your house.
Imagine someone describing the direct shape
of your insides while informing you what your
relative across the country is doing.
Would you not also cry out ‘Angel?
Angel?!
Where are you, Angel!’”
After this introductory portion, and taking
a moment to plug his book “The Life in Plane”
- which was co-authored by Iotis himself - Michalis
opened the floor to questions.
One of the Junior Researchers asked why the
residents of SCP-6011 look so human.
Michalis responded with a question of his
own: “do they even look human?
Or is it natural for our brain to make connections
between vaguely humanoid-shaped objects, as
we want to feel a sense of familiarity with
them?”
Michalis confirmed that, after a significant
amount of testing, SCP-6011 is definitely
two-dimensional.
Somehow, it has no width.
Because of this dimensional difference between
SCP-6011 and the ordinary world, nothing should
be removed from the boundaries of the flat
world.
Forcing a two-dimensional object or being
into our world would cause it to either rearrange
itself to fit into a three-dimensional configuration
or cause it to split apart.
At best, it would become malformed.
At worst, the item would undergo instantaneous
nuclear fission.
Nothing can be placed inside of SCP-6011 from
the outside world either.
Three-dimensional objects can pass through
temporarily, showing only a cross-section
of the object.
The Foundation advises against attempting
to place any objects inside, as it would change
the Enthalpy of the system.
During his observation of SCP-6011, as well
as his interviews with Iotis, Dr. Michalis
uncovered a wide variety of facts about life
inside the flat earth.
The Plana hominem live in a feudal society,
where people are born into a class position
and the role of the parents is passed along
to their offspring.
The social hierarchy is broken down into Estates.
The Estates are indicated by a color applied
under the skin of each person at their birth.
There is no opportunity for upward mobility,
or for fall from grace, only to stay in the
position one is born into.
Those of the Red estate belong to the monarchy
of SCP-6011.
The Orange are administrators.
The Yellow are priests, scribes, and record
keepers.
The Green are similar to the middle-class
of 18th century Europe, encompassing teachers,
physicians, lawyers, and other educated professionals.
Blue are merchants, tradesmen, and skilled
workers, and Purple are the manual laborers.
Because of the difficulty of accomplishing
tasks in only two dimensions, the upper-class
citizens have at least two servants apiece.
All servants come from the estates ranked
below Green.
Because physical writing is difficult in the
boundaries of SCP-6011, members of the Yellow
caste are trained as “Voice Scribes.”
They memorize and repeat large amounts of
information, such as entire books, transcriptions
of speeches, or laws.
Entertainment in SCP-6011 is largely voice-based
as well, with Visual Theatres considered a
luxury only for the highest-class citizens.
The entertainment of the common people is
found in the Voice Theater, a place where
entertainment is structured around dialogue
and the sound of artificially created ambiance.
Naturally, the Foundation does not want any
civilians stumbling on SCP-6011.
Though it poses no threat to humanity, knowledge
of its existence could cause chaos and could
very well endanger the inhabitants of SCP-6011.
Site 044 was set up around SCP-6011 in order
to protect it.
No construction is permitted within a 10-kilometer
radius of the area, under a cover story about
the Libyan government blocking off the area
for conservation purposes.
SCP-6011 is stored in a hermetically sealed
chamber, away from external influences.
All interactions with SCP-6011 or any of the
organisms living within it must be approved
by the Head Researcher of Provisional Site
044.
A monitoring system is set up perpendicular
to SCP-6011 so that the research team can
keep an eye on the activity inside, without
disturbing the residents.
The monitoring system is, unfortunately, not
without its flaws.
One day, there was a malfunction in the system
that caused the breakdown of the camera rails,
and several metallic components came loose
and plunged into the surface of SCP-6011.
There was no damage, but the objects were
seen by several citizens.
The Foundation was concerned that the sight
of massive pieces of mysterious objects appearing
and disappearing suddenly in a public space
would cause mass panic among the people of
SCP-6011.
However, the research team was shocked to
see the two-dimensional people carrying on
with their ordinary day-to-day lives.
They performed an anti-cognitohazard screening
in order to determine what was causing this
strangely placid response to what should have
been a devastating shock to the people.
They discovered a large building, hidden by
a form of visual cognitohazard, shaped like
an octagon.
Further monitoring of this unusual building
captured a voice recording of a Scribe reciting
an account of the monitor equipment disaster.
Soon after, Iotis was removed from his home
by officers that refused to disclose what
organization they were working for.
All of this, the building, the arrest, the
report of the incident, was traced to a secret
organization operating inside of SCP-6011
known as the Doctors of the Church.
The group was made up of Yellow and Orange
Estate members, with a small selection of
Green, Blue, and Purple Field Agents.
The research team could not help but notice
how similar the Doctors of the Church are
to the Foundation itself.
Their mission statements are very much the
same, upholding a veil of secrecy between
the unusual and the population they have sworn
to protect while working to understand the
anomalies they are trying to conceal.
All three-dimensional interlopers are scrubbed
from the public consciousness or hidden from
the people at large.
Further research indicated that the incident
would have completely destroyed 6011 if the
Doctors of the Church had not worked to deploy
reality anchors to keep the baseline reality
of the world intact.
Dr. Michalis wrote about this group, affectionately
nicknamed “The Little Foundation,” saying:
“When I look at them I see – well- us.”
And “A little crumb of limestone falling
from the ceiling of the karst or a bug somehow
making its way onto the surface of SCP-6011
— phasing in and out of existence — must
have terrified them.
And so they found a way to conceal all that
was illogical from the general public.
As did we.”
The reality of SCP-6011 raises some fascinating,
if a bit troubling, questions.
What dimensions are there that we have no
knowledge of?
Just as the two-dimensional being cannot conceive
of us, what four-dimensional beings, five-dimensional
beings, and so on might there be out there
that we can’t begin to wrap our heads around?
To a creature with no concept of a third dimension,
creatures that exist within our world seem
like angels or even Gods.
Perhaps the things in this world we cannot
explain are simply creatures that exist in
more dimensions than we are able to conceive
of.
Truly, there may be no difference between
The Little Foundation and the SCP Foundation
that we know.
Looking down at the residents of SCP-6011,
and all that they think they know, might encourage
us to feel superior.
Instead, it should make us curious, and perhaps
even make us afraid of what we might be unable
to understand.
Dr. Michalis summarized his thoughts on SCP-6011
in its file:
“We had prior interactions with entities
that claimed to originate from higher geometrical
dimensions, yet our mind was never really
capable of understanding them.
Where we stand, we have the capability to
imagine the lives of those in the 2-dimensional
space.
Sadly, the same cannot be said for our understanding
of the 4-dimensional reality.
It is often said that the human brain is like
a computer.
So just like a computer can never completely
emulate a machine more advanced than itself,
so do we lack the ability to understand higher
dimensions.”
To a creature outside of our understanding,
we are the citizens of the Flat Earth, shuffling
back and forth, unable to see that which lies
beyond.
Now go check out “SCP-999 - The Tickle Monster”
and “SCP-978 - Desire Camera” for more
Safe but Scintillating SCP’s!